lovely to see you how are you it's good
thank you again yeah I get it because I
went to see Michael in concert yeah yeah
it was so good I saw your film as well
that's pretty good
it was nice too cuz I could see you
there was a point where I was singing
and I looked back and all I saw you you
had I think of glass of wine I did yeah
saw it very clearly and the other you're
doing this you you've worked with
Jennifer haven't you yes I was on her
special yeah and we've we've met up at
different things
yeah and have you met Dame Judi Dench
before no we have now yes supposed to
meet you I don't know does Matthew know
that he plays a special part in your
life uh no probably not
please I play the part yeah can't wait
to get this dose well I mean I my wife
and I sleep with you almost every night
yes yeah and every night there's an app
called calm and I have insomnia and he
has the most beautiful voice and I turn
it on and I just hear well hello
everybody it's me Matthew McConaughey
I'm gonna tell you a bedtime story and I
just do this oh ho
I honestly got to the box my wife was
from Argentina she always goes like you
have the man talking again stop being in
a baby game
it's great though I love it it cost me
80 bucks it was more worth out have you
because I just sort of wish you reading
search but you are actually putting
people to bed this is this is method
economy on the app tonight I hope to
send you after peaceful dreams with that
very thing in mind let's your eyes
closed and your breath fall soft and
slow as we begin our story but just
might rekindle that sense of wonder
[Applause]
it's hard to keep going the score is
actually real interest
[Music]
you